like doing research and I was like enter
it's true and I was like it's like Oh II
have a girlfriend I was like oh my god
that's his mom oh my gosh we need please
but my mom is a fox
I'm so happy you just said that she's
gonna be so happy so that yeah she
really is she's my biggest fan and I'm
I'm her see she's just me one cool lady
good genes run in the family i sat down
with black waste our alexander ludwig to
talk about everything from yes his mom
to his acting career to even early
modeling days you're an Abercrombie
model not really there are so many
actors that are Abercrombie models
Jennifer Lawrence - yeah but they really
cool good I have a cover oh yeah you're
so not cool I was in college and I had
been asked randomly this had nothing to
do it that I had done films before by
somebody if I wanted to go to Montauk
for three days and and I was single at
the time I was like a big great way to
meet are you not single man I know at
that time I was this time I am
completely yeah I have um so it ended up
happening and it was an amazing shoot
and it was also with Bruce Weber who
whose work I had I've been familiar with
and I thought he was an incredible
photographer so I thought it was a great
experience and then when I got to the
set people have realized that I'd done
some stuff before like the hell is going
on okay yeah so it was it was a very
funny funny experience it was amazing